all right now we have another combustion
reaction instead of instead of ethylene
we now have ethane c2h6 has two carbons
and six hydrogen atoms in each molecule
of ethane and it is reacting its ethane
gas it's reacting with molecular oxygen
in gaseous form and they combust to form
carbon dioxide gas and liquid water and
like we've seen in previous examples
this chemical equation is not balanced
how can we tell well here on the left
hand side we have two carbons here on
the right hand side we have one carbon
here on the left hand side we have six
hydrogen's here on the right hand side
we only have two hydrogen's here on the
left hand side we have two oxygens on
the right hand side we have two plus
three oxygens so all of the out none of
the elements here are balanced but like
we did in the example with ethylene
whenever you see this where you have you
know several you know somewhat complex
molecules involved it's good to save the
element that is in a molecule by itself
for last because you can just tweak this
to change the number of oxygens without
having any other side effects on the
number of carbons or hydrogen's so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to first
balance like we've done before the
carbons and the hydrogen's which is
which are going to have implications on
the oxygens because if I change the
number here it's gonna change the number
of oxygens if I change the number here
it's gonna change the number of oxygens
but lucky for me I have this dioxygen
molecule on the left-hand side that I
can just tweak at the end to balance the
entire chemical equation so let's start
with you know last time we started with
carbon let's start with hydrogen this
time just for kicks so over here I have
six hydrogen's on the left hand side or
the entire left hand side only have six
hydrogen atoms on the right hand side I
only have two right now so if I want to
have if I want to have six I would
multiply these two by three so now I
have three water molecules each of them
have two hydrogen atoms so I'm going to
have six six hydrogen atoms on the right
hand side fair enough now let's go to
the carbon remember I'm saving oxygen
for last carbon on the left-hand side I
have two carbons how many carbons do I
have
on the right hand side well right now I
only have one but I can change that very
easily instead of having one molecule of
carbon dioxide I can have two molecules
of carbon dioxide and so now my carbons
are balanced two carbons two carbons and
now let's go to the oxygens so right now
right now on I'll do this in a move
color alright now on the left hand side
I have two oxygens but on the right hand
side what do I have let's see F two
times two so this right over here is
four oxygens and then I have three water
molecules each of them have one oxygen
atom so three times one so this is going
to be three right over here so on the
entire right hand side I have seven
oxygen atoms and on the left-hand side
only have two so what can I do here can
i what can I multiply by 2 to get to 7 2
times what is equal to 7 well 2 times 3
and 1/2 is equal to 7 so 2 times 3 and
1/2 is equal to 7 remember I have 2 here
I'm saying 2 times something is equal to
7 I want to get to the 4 plus the 3 well
I multiply it by 3.5 and now I have 7 7
oxygen atoms on both sides of my
chemical equation but like we've seen in
previous videos it is not standard to
just leave a three and a half here it's
kind of this weird notion of three and a
half molecules we like to have whole
numbers here so how do we how do we
change how do we make sure we have all
whole number coefficients in front of
our molecules well we could just
multiply everything by two then this
thing is going to become a seven this
thing is going to become a two this is
going to become a four this is going to
become a six so let's just do that I'll
write the whole reaction over again so I
have my ethane and I won't write
actually what state it's in just just to
save some time plus some molecular
oxygen they combust the yield so these
are the reactants the products are
carbon dioxide gas and liquid water and
liquid water so let's see you multiply
if you say that there was a one out here
before we're going to multiply that by
two to get two we
a three point five year multiply that by
two you get a seven here we had a two
right over here multiply that by two you
get a four once again I'm just
multiplying boats at all the
coefficients by two just like you did in
an algebraic equation in your algebra
classes and then finally three times two
is six and we're all balanced we were
balanced here but we had we didn't have
whole number of coefficients multiplying
everything by two gave us the whole
number of coefficients and we are much
happier